OK.
I want to have a conversation about polling
that is a careful conversation and a sober
conversation, because there's been a narrative
building over the last maybe 10 to 14 days
that Biden is falling.
And Trump is rising.
And that this is objectively a disaster for
Joe Biden and Donald Trump has actually applied
the term plunging for George.
Now, not not for someone's neck line, who
he's trying to talk to, but plunging from
the standpoint of Joe Biden's polling.
Now, the reality is, when we started getting
these polls two months ago that said Biden
is up by 10, Biden is up by 12.
Biden is up by 15.
I told you, Joe Biden is not going to win
the popular vote by 15, nor by 12, nor by
10.
The polls are going to tighten.
And depending on how you look at it, the polls
are tightening.
Joe Biden is starting to campaign in a bit
of a different way as a result as we get closer
to the election.
And that makes sense.
Donald Trump tweeting, as I told you yesterday,
quote, Joe Biden is coming out of the basement
earlier than his hoped for ten days because
his people told him he has no choice.
His poll numbers are plunging.
So let's know the facts.
But let's also not become overconfident as
a result of those facts.
So, first of all, have the polling average
has tightened?
You can always find one poll that will say
almost whatever you want.
But what about the averages?
The real Clear Politics average was Biden
plus nine point five.
A couple of months ago.
And it's tightened by a couple of points to
Biden plus seven, OK?
It's tighter.
We never really expected Biden to win by 10
in the popular vote would have been completely
historic.
And indeed, the numbers have tightened from
Biden with a nearly 10 point lead to a seven
point lead in the 538 polling average model.
You see that Joe Biden now is plus seven point
seven.
At one point he was plus nine point six.
That was back in early July.
So, yes, the polls have tightened.
Is Joe Biden plunging?
No, the answer is no.
And of course, Donald Trump lies all the time.
He lies and says coronaviruses surging in
New Zealand when it's not.
He says he's done a great job on the virus
when he is not.
He said in April, fifteen cases would soon
be zero.
That didn't happen.
We have six million.
Just because Donald Trump is wrong about Joe
Biden's polling plunging doesn't mean Trump
can't necessarily win.
And that's where I want to sort of go next.
It's really important that our actions not
be influenced by these dumb narratives that
are put out there, either by Donald Trump
or others is poll.
If polling is tightening, you have to vote
and I have to vote.
If polling is not tightening, you have to
vote and I have to vote.
If Trump is true, is right that Biden's polling
is plunging, you have to vote and I have to
vote.
That's the primary message here.
And I know it's like a broken record at this
point, but you're only going to have to deal
with it for two, two more months, which are
arguably going to be long months, but it's
only two more months.
And as a reminder.
If you go back to September 1st of 2016 and
look at the polling between Hillary Clinton
and Donald Trump, September one, 2016 for
Mike, four years ago today, Hillary Clinton
was plus four point nine.
And, of course, we know she ultimately lost
the electoral college.
Is Biden's lead bigger as of today?
Yes, it's almost three points bigger than
Hillary's.
Four years ago.
But so what?
Why take a chance?
Because there are things going on this year
that are not in the polls.
In other words, voter purges are not part
of Biden's seven point lead right now.
Planned voter suppression is not part of the
seven point lead Joe Biden has right now,
messing with vote by mail and the post office
and everything we've been talking about for
the last six weeks.
That is not in the polls right now.
Voter intimidation at the polls.
This vague idea that there might be someone
who knows a militia, troops who who knows
what at the polls intimidating voters.
That's not in the polls.
So let's act as if.
Remember, your vote could decide the outcome
of your state individually.
It's unlikely any of our one votes will do
that.
But collectively, if we all thought our vote
didn't matter and stayed home, we actually
would be influencing the results of the states.
So that's the correct approach.
There's no downside.
Joe Biden's polling is not plunging.
It's tightening as expected.
We've got about eight weeks to go.
And this is the time up.
Let me know where you are on the polling.
I'm on Twitter at the Spackman.
And remember that you can get the daily audio
podcast every single day on whichever is your
preferred podcasting platform.
I tunes stitcher, Google Play, Spotify, Pandora
Pod, Biehn, etc..
There's a lot of them.
We'll see you in just a couple
of minutes.